hey guys it is Monday the 21st up
November my name is just and here's the
things that mattered in gaming today so
sup uncharted 4 is getting co-op as part
of a new mode called uncharted for
survival the wave based mode pits you
and up to two friends against hordes of
increasingly difficult enemies should
you be unable to find friends to play
with you can also tuck into the mode
solo the co-op mode sounds like it will
be similar to uncharted 2 and 3 scorp
arena mode Naughty Dog game designer
vineet agarwal explained in a
playstation blog post we've built upon
and evolved the core gameplay experience
with an entirely new level of depth
challenge and variety from new enemy
types and powerful new bosses to
dedicated progression system and
expansive upgradeable arsenal survival
is all about strategy camaraderie and
skill survival has 10 maps and 50 total
waves of enemies after every ten waves
you'll face off against legendary
pirates from the game's campaign you
also need to complete objectives adapter
on the fly modifiers and ultimately earn
cash to weapon upgrades and items for
more info check out our story on sites
next up Fallout New Vegas is getting
drivable vehicles and space travel
thanks to mudders a large team of
modders have created a new total
conversion mod called the frontier the
mod includes new weapons monsters and
environment as well as voiced characters
drivable vehicles space flight and
on-the-fly weapon modification all of
which should help alleviate the fact
that flat for wasn't as good as you'd
hoped it was going to be the frontier
tells the story of general blackthorn
who's attempting to overthrow president
kimball of the new California Republic
blackthorn is then exiled to the
frontier and must fight his way back
while the mod doesn't have a release
date as yet the team has opened a
discord channel for anyone who wants to
chat with them about it Final Fantasy 15
s day one update has been detailed and
in less positive news it's strict date
has also been broken early square enix
has revealed that the crown update adds
new cut scenes from the King slave movie
and omen trailer to make the story and
timeline of events easier to follow and
add
and for new players the patch also adds
more cooking recipes a gallery for
culinary discoveries support for sharing
screenshots to social media and an
ability tree for the wait mode feature
which lets play a slow down time there
will also be a based whistle included
which can be used to back in monsters
into battle the update additionally
fixes a number of bugs for the full
patch notes and check out our story on
games floods well that's all well and
good unfortunately Final Fantasy 15 has
leaked across South America ahead of its
intended November 29 release date
numerous streams have popped out from
users who got their hands on an early
copy game director Hajime Tabata said
unfortunately there has been an
unauthorized distribution of the boxed
edition of Final Fantasy 15 in select
regions and who've noticed the gameplay
footage from people playing these copies
has appeared online he adds videos with
unexpected spoilers could potentially be
posted online so we would like to warn
everyone who's been waiting in
anticipation for this game will also do
everything in our capacity to prevent
unauthorized footage from appearing
online be sure to leave me your thoughts
about today's stories down in that
comment box ahead to game spot for our
tips on Pokemon Sun and Moon and I will
see you again tomorrow